Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. At New Balance, we believe if you run, you're a a runner however you choose to do it because when you're not worried about doing things the right way you're free to discover your way and that's what running's all about
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、提前解锁系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在 New Balance，我们坚信只要你跑步，你就是一名跑者，无论你选择以何种方式跑，因为当你不再担心是否用正确的方式跑时，你就能自由探索属于你自己的方式，这正是跑步的真谛所在。
run your way at newbalance.com slash running. The great agricultural tracts produced no grain. The inundated tracts produced no fish. The irrigated orchards produced neither syrup nor wine. The gathered clouds did not rain. The Mazgurum did not grow. At that time, one shekel's worth of oil was only one half quart. One shekel's worth of grain was only one half quart. These sold at such prices in the market of all the cities. He who slept on
在 newbalance.com 斜杠 running，跑出你的专属方式。大片农业区没有产出粮食。被淹没的区没有产出鱼类。受灌溉的果园既不产糖浆也不产酒。聚拢的乌云没有下雨。马兹古鲁姆没有生长。当时，一谢克尔价值的油只有半夸脱。一谢克尔价值的粮食只有半夸脱。这些在所有城市的市场上都是这个价。睡在
the roof died on the roof. He who slept in the house had no burial. People were flailing at themselves from hunger. A cad, instead of its sweet flowing water, there flowed bitter water. Whoever said, I will dwell in that, found not a good dwelling place. Whoever said, I will lie down in a cad, found not a good sleeping place. That was terrifying, Dominic. That's a chilling reading. There's a chilling word, chillingly delivered. I think it's fair to say. Very, very chillingly delivered. And I know that you think about the curse of Akkad most days, don't you? I do.
屋顶的人死在了屋顶上。睡在屋子里的人没有得到安葬。人们因为饥饿而捶打自己。在阿卡德，原本流淌着甜美的水，流淌出的却是苦水。无论谁说：“我将住在那里”，都没有找到一个好的住处。无论谁说：“我将躺在阿卡德”，都没有找到一个好的安歇处。那太可怕了，多米尼克。这是一段令人不寒栗的朗读。这是一个令人毛骨悚然的词，以令人毛骨悚然的方式朗读出来。我觉得这样说很公允。非常、非常令人毛骨悚然地朗读出来。我知道你几乎每天都在思考阿卡德的诅咒，对吧？我是的。
It's something that really plays on your mind. I do. So would you like to share your nightmare with the listeners? So the curse of Akkad is composed around 2250 BC. And it has been adduced as an example of the theme of today's episode which dominic is climate apocalypse cheery cheery for uh yeah well because i i wanted to call it climate change and you insisted on calling it climate apocalypse yeah that's what we're going to do i have the instinct tom of a top newspaper editor i think it's fair to say. I know you do. So the question is, though, is that what you so
这是真正萦绕在你心头的事情。我是的。那你愿意和听众分享你的噩梦吗？所以阿卡德的诅咒大约创作于公元前 2250 年。它被作为今天这一集主题的一个例证，多米尼克，这就是气候末日——真令人高兴，对吧？——呃，是的，好吧，因为我——我本想叫它气候变化，而你坚持要叫它气候 apocalypse（气候末日）——对，我们就打算这么做。汤姆，我觉得我可以算是一个顶级报纸编辑的直觉，这样说很公允。我知道你确实有。所以问题是，你刚才那个
terrifyingly and sonorously read out? Is it a record of climate change, of climate apocalypse, or is it something more ambivalent, more complicated? And as it happens, we have the absolute perfect person on hand to answer that question for us. And that is none other than Peter Frankopan, who is Professor of Global History at Oxford University, international man of mystery, a man who never knowingly wears a shirt without unbuttoning it to his navel. And he is the author of a new book that's just come out, The Earth Transformed, which Peter, you're naturally a very modest man, I know. You must feel very embarrassed by how well it's been reviewed, the kind of splash it's made. I'm still in shock listening to Dominic's
可怕而又铿锵有力地朗读出来的东西，究竟是气候变化、气候末日的记录，还是某种更加矛盾、更加复杂的东西？而恰巧的是，我们手头有一个绝佳的人选来为我们解答这个问题。他不是别人，正是牛津大学全球历史教授彼得·弗兰科潘（Peter Frankopan），国际神秘男子，一个只要穿衬衫，绝不会把扣子扣到肚脐以上的人。他是一本刚刚出版的新书《地球的变迁》（The Earth Transformed）的作者，彼得，我知道你天性是个非常谦虚的人。对于这本书受到的好评如潮以及它所引发的轰动，你一定感到非常不好意思。我听了多米尼克在
fine performance in Trading the Boards. I mean, I was going to say how great it is to come onto your history podcast, but I think you're in the wrong career, Dominic, that's Royal Shakespeare Company calls. You're not the first to say that, Peter, and you won't be the last, let's be frank. A lot of listeners will know that I was cruelly denied. You probably don't know this, Peter, unless you followed my career as closely as you should have done. But I was cruelly denied the role of Paddington, which was given to Ben Whishaw instead,
播音时的精彩表现，至今还在震惊中。我的意思是，我本来想说来到你们的历史播客是多么棒的一件事，但我觉得你入错了行，多米尼克，皇家莎士比亚剧团在召唤你呢。你不是第一个这么说的人，彼得，而且坦白讲，你也不会是最后一个。很多听众都会知道我曾被残酷地剥夺了。彼得，你可能不知道这一点——除非你像你应该做的那样密切关注我的职业生涯。但我被残酷地剥夺了扮演帕丁顿熊的角色，这个角色后来给了本·威士肖（Ben Whishaw），
because I'd worked with the director. The station or the... Not the station. I could play the station if there was an anthropomorphic railway station. But we're going off piste already, Tom. You warned this would happen. Yes, yes.
因为我曾和导演合作过。那个车站还是……不是车站。如果有拟人化的火车站的话，我可以演车站。但我们已经偏离正题了，汤姆。你警告过会这样的。是的，是的。
So Peter, your book, The Earth Transformed, is basically a history about how climate has influenced the history of humanity right the way up to the present. And because Dominic has insisted on calling this climate apocalypse, we thought we would begin with that, which is a very early example from the beginnings of urban civilization. Akkad is often adduced as the first example of an empire. So what are the complexities in deciding whether that is a record of climate change?
那么，彼得，你的书《地球的变迁》基本上是一部关于气候如何影响人类历史直至当下的历史。由于多米尼克坚持将此称为气候末日，我们觉得可以从这个非常早期的城市文明发端时期的例子开始讲起。阿卡德常被引为帝国的第一例。那么，在判断这是否属于气候变化的记录时，有哪些复杂性呢？
Well, never trust a historian. That's the first problem. When people write things down about dying on roofs and starvation and hunger, the tabloid editors of the past were equally as ferocious and committed as they are today. So I think never let the facts get in the way of a good story. So I think quite often with history, and you hear about devastation, collapse, famines, droughts, you have to be extremely cautious about taking what you're reading with a pinch of salt. And in fact, in this particular case, what makes it so helpful to us is that we don't have to rely on historians to check what's going on because we can look at a whole bunch of new types of sciences to be able to measure everything ranging from levels in ice cores to be able to tell what's happening to
嗯，永远不要相信历史学家。这是第一个问题。当人们把关于死在屋顶上、饥荒和饥饿的事情写下来时，过去的八卦小报编辑和今天的一样凶猛且投入。所以我觉得，永远不要让事实妨碍一个好故事。因此我认为，在面对历史时，当你听到关于毁灭、崩溃、饥荒、干旱的消息时，你必须极其谨慎，对你所读到的内容持保留态度。事实上，在这种特殊情况下，之所以对我们如此有帮助，是因为我们不必依赖历史学家去核实到底发生了什么，因为我们可以研究一整套新型科学，从而能够测量从冰芯中的水平，以确定
carbon dioxide levels through to fossilized pollen in the case of the curse of Akkad or around about 2250 BC, so four and a half thousand years ago, you can see changes to the records in Oman, in southwestern Iran. You can see there's a dramatic series of changes that have happened to the natural environment. Now, that doesn't necessarily mean that human beings start to collapse, but it means that the conditions around us change. And, you know, my book is not just about climate, it's about the natural world as a whole. And I think all of us realise that the natural world is always changing, not just because the sun shines brighter or the rains don't come, but also because the ways in which those landscapes are transformed. I mean, obviously, most obviously by human beings, but, you know, we're not the only species on this earth that's changed the way in which land gets used. You know, other big mammals
二氧化碳水平的变化，到化石花粉——以阿卡德的诅咒为例，大约在公元前 2250 年，也就是四千五百年前，你可以看到阿曼、伊朗西南部记录的变化。你可以看到自然环境发生了一系列戏剧性的变化。现在，这并不一定意味着人类开始崩溃，但这意味着我们周围的条件发生了变化。而且，你知道，我的书不仅仅是关于气候的，它是关于整个自然界的。我想我们所有人都意识到，自然界一直在变化，不仅是因为太阳照得更亮或雨水没有降临，还因为这些景观被改造的方式。我的意思是，很显然，最明显的是人类造成的，但是，你知道的，我们并不是地球上唯一一个改变土地使用方式的物种。你知道的，其他大型哺乳动物
in particular, are huge disturbers of vegetation, and all sorts of different animals, including very, very small ones that we don't pay any attention to and get very badly treated by people who complain about the natural world and are worried about climate change. We tend to overprioritize big animals. And the little ones, like termites and mosquitoes moths things like that are hugely important in our ecosystems too so in in this particular case we can see that there is a moment of stress uh what climatic stress most times when that happens most times when you have hot summers uh problems don't come and in the case of naram sin the son of the great or the grandson of the great Sargon of Akkad, who is the kind of great Donald Trump of the Mesopotamian world. Although there is clearly a series of shocks that go through the
特别是植被的巨大破坏者，还有各种各样的动物，包括那些我们根本不关注、被抱怨自然环境和担心气候变化的人虐待得非常惨的非常非常小的动物。我们往往过分优先考虑大型动物。而那些小的动物，比如白蚁、蚊子、飞蛾之类的小东西，在我们的生态系统中也极其重要。所以在这个特定的案例中，我们可以看到这是一个处于压力下的时刻，呃，什么样的气候压力？大多数情况下，当这种情况发生时，大多数情况下，当你有炎热的夏天时，问题并不会出现。而在纳拉姆·辛（Naram-Sin）——伟大的萨尔贡的儿子，或者伟大的阿卡德的萨尔贡的孙子，他有点像美索不达米亚世界的伟大唐纳德·特朗普——尽管系统中明显有一系列冲击。事实上，发生的事情是，纳拉姆·辛利用这个机会巩固和集中权力，
system. In fact, what happens is that Naram-Sin uses that as an opportunity to consolidate and centralise power, which is what good rulers do. And as you've covered so well in many of your other episodes, never let a good crisis go to waste so a lot depends on what it is you you're looking for and there's the historian the lightness of touch of using these new data materials that we have as a way of adding texture rather than trying to sort of upend the apple carton the volume and the range and accuracy of these materials is is incredibly profound and also enormously exciting. And so these are new developments? Yeah, I mean, they've been two or three decades in the coming.
这正是优秀的统治者所做的。正如你在许多其他单集中非常出色地探讨过的那样，永远不要浪费一场好的危机。所以很大程度上取决于你在寻找什么，以及历史学家的态度：以轻描淡写的笔触，利用我们拥有的这些新数据材料来增添质感，而不是试图去打破苹果车。这些材料的体量、范围和准确性是极其深远的，同时也极其令人兴奋。所以这些都是新的进展？是的，我的意思是，它们已经酝酿了二三十年。
But I mean, now the thing that's moving by far the fastest in my world as a historian, our worlds as historians, you know, every now and again, somebody finds a text that they haven't seen before. Every now and again, you know, you get an Indiana Jones type discovery. There's this amazing CIA declassification of satellite photos over Afghanistan and the former Soviet Union that allow us, particularly when it has been dry these last couple of summers, extra dry, to spot things from the air that we didn't know were there. Caravans arise and structures, canals, things like that. But in the world of historical discoveries, works on genomics, works to help us with migrations, works on ice cores, tree rings, fossilized pollens, all the kind of biological sciences. But specifically on this question about ACAD, it's kind of very Daily Mail,
但我的意思是，现在作为一名历史学家，在我的世界里——我们作为历史学家的世界里——进展最快的事情是，每隔一段时间，就会有人发现他们以前没见过的文本。每隔一段时间，你就会遇到印第安纳·琼斯式的发现。美国中情局解密了阿富汗和前苏联上空的大量卫星照片，这让我们——特别是过去几个夏天格外干燥的时候——能够从空中发现我们以前不知道存在的东西。商队路线、建筑、运河之类。但在历史发现的世界里，基因组学研究、帮助我们了解人类迁徙的研究、冰芯、树木年轮、化石花粉研究，所有这类生物科学都在发展。但具体到关于阿卡德的这个问题，它有点像《每日邮报》的风格，
property prices falling, all that kind of stuff. Fuck Dominic Paul's face. There's obviously drama inherent in making things sound as bad as possible. It sells the equivalent of newspapers, whatever they had in a cad. Tablets. Tablets, yes. But to what extent does the description of it, can we test from new scientific developments, how accurate those descriptions are? Yeah, in this particular case, four and a half thousand years ago, we would ideally have a greater set of written records to be able to explain what exactly is going on. I mean, there are a set of obvious things that one would look for when you have climate stress or food shortages, whether it's climate or otherwise.
房价下跌，诸如此类。去他的多米尼克·保罗的脸。把事情说得尽可能糟糕，这本身就蕴含着戏剧性。它能卖出相当于报纸的东西，不管他们在阿卡德叫什么。泥板。泥板，是的。但是，对于对其描述的程度，我们可以从新的科学发展中检验这些描述有多准确吗？是的，在这个特定的案例中，四千五百年前，我们理想情况下应该有一套更丰富的文字记录来解释到底发生了什么。我的意思是，当你面临气候压力或粮食短缺（无论是由于气候还是其他原因）时，人们通常会寻找一些显而易见的东西。
And that would normally be, as we all know today, inflation, cosi-lives, cost of living crises. This happened millennia ago. Can we read it in the scientific record? Are there ways of stress testing how accurate these descriptions are? Is this what's happened over the past three decades? Yes. I mean, in the case of Sargon of Akkad, going back four and a half thousand years, quite close to the beginning of when writing systems have come into play, it's a kind of totemic boundary point, 2200, because in fact, there are lots of things that are happening in other parts of the world at about the same time. So as a kind of curse of Akkad, because we've got this text that Dominic read out so poetically, that is a kind of lightning rod to
而这通常会是，正如我们今天所知，通货膨胀、生活成本危机。这种情况在几千年前就发生过了。我们能在科学记录中读到它吗？有没有办法对这些描述的准确性进行压力测试？这就是过去三十年所发生的事情吗？是的。我的意思是，就阿卡德的萨尔贡而言，追溯到四五千年前，非常接近书写系统开始发挥作用的起点，这是一个具有图腾意义的分界点，即公元前 2200 年，因为事实上，在大约同一时期，世界其他地方也正在发生许多事情。因此，作为一种阿卡德的诅咒，因为我们有了多米尼克富有诗意地朗读出来的这段文本，这就像一根引雷针，
draw attention to the Sargon of Akkad. But I mean, I think what historians tend to do when they run with these ideas about collapses, they tend to focus on people at the top. So if you have a civilizational collapse or societal problems, that's bad if you're a member of the elite, but it's maybe not so bad if you're not one of the priests, one of the rulers. So in the case of the Curse of Akkad,
用来吸引人们对阿卡德的萨尔贡的注意。但是，我认为历史学家在顺着这些关于崩溃的想法进行研究时，往往倾向于关注高层人物。因此，如果你发生了文明崩溃或社会问题，如果你是精英阶层的一员，那是很糟糕的；但如果你不是祭司之一、不是统治者之一，也许就没那么糟糕。所以在阿卡德的诅咒这个案例中，
there's a whole system of global changes that's now named by scientists the Megalean period or the breakpoint, because the sheer volume of climatic data from that period is so voluminous. In terms of pinpointing individual cases like Sargon of Akkad, we want to have more written materials. And we shouldn't forget that a thousand years before Sargon, we've got almost nothing to go with at all. But that record starts to warm up and get much more plentiful as we reach other periods. So we have to do a bit of, I wouldn't say creative thinking, but a bit of plotting. What does this look like compared to other similar kinds of cases? And like I already said, Naram-Sin, who is the subject of these terrible,
现在有一整套全球变化的系统被科学家命名为“梅加莱亚期”（Megalean period）或“断裂点”，因为那个时期的气候数据量太庞大了。就精确定位像阿卡德的萨尔贡这样的个案而言，我们希望有更多的文字资料。我们不应该忘记，在萨尔贡之前的一千年里，我们几乎一无所有。但随着我们进入其他时期，这些记录开始升温并变得更加丰富。因此，我们必须做一点——我不会说是创造性思考，而是一点绘制工作。与类似的其他案例相比，这看起来是怎样的？就像我之前已经说过的那样，成为这些可怕的——
well, it's not a curse, but of the crises, is able to consolidate his position and build an empire afterwards. So whatever the challenge that he goes through, it's obviously not totally cataclysmic because he's able to reboot. But that's good for him. It's maybe not so good if you're coerced labour, it's not so good if you're a slave, not so good if you are someone who hasn't made it through your rooftop seance where you starve to death. But life does go on in history. Just on the using this as a sort of metaphor for the bigger story, would it be fair to say that people have always been haunted by this idea of climate apocalypse?
好吧，这其实不是诅咒，而是危机——的主角纳拉姆·辛，能够在事后巩固自己的地位并建立一个帝国。因此，无论他经历了什么挑战，显然都不是完全毁灭性的，因为他能够重新启动。但这对他是好事。如果你是受强迫的劳工，这就未必是好事；如果你是个奴隶，这就未必是好事；如果你是一个没有在屋顶派对中熬过来、最终饿死的人，这就未必是好事。但历史上的生活仍在继续。仅仅就以此作为更大故事的一种隐喻而言，是否可以公平地说，人们一直被这种气候末日的想法所困扰？
Or are we back projecting and these are just sort of ordinary mundane anxieties about the harvest or about, you know, invasion or fire and flood or whatever? Or do you think there is something deeper that's always lurked in the background? There's definitely something deeper. Go to the story of the creation. I mean, that is a book of Genesis, chapter one, book one. It's all about how the ideal scenario has been created on earth in the case of the Judaic, Christian and Islamic faiths for the benefit of humans. And if you transgress and you anger God, you're punished ecologically and environmentally. I mean, if you're booted out of the Garden of Eden for not obeying orders,
还是说我们在进行回溯投射，这些只是一种对丰收、对入侵、对火灾和洪水或诸如此类事情的普通、世俗的焦虑？还是说你认为有一种更深层的东西一直潜伏在背景中？绝对有更深层的东西。去看看创世记的故事。我的意思是，那是创世记第一章，第一卷。在犹太教、基督教和伊斯兰教的信仰中，这一切都是关于理想的场景如何在地球上为了人类的利益而被创造出来的。如果你违背了戒律并激怒了上帝，你就会在生态和环境上受到惩罚。我的意思是，如果你因为不听命令而被踢出伊甸园，
you are forced to grow crops in dusty conditions and to face hardship. So I think in the Western Abrahamic traditions, I think the idea about anxiety is extremely close. And of course, Noah and the floods, which we see in the Sumerian flood story, we see in the Atrahasis, in other Mesopotamian texts, obviously leaves a huge imprint on the anxieties of people around what happens if climate conditions shift or deliver unexpected shocks. And the reason those are written down is to communicate the anxieties to future generations. I mean, that's what historians do. Otherwise, you just chat about it.
你就会被迫在尘土飞扬的条件下面对庄稼的生长和艰难困苦。所以我认为在西方亚伯拉罕传统中，我认为关于焦虑的想法是非常接近的。当然，诺亚方舟和洪水——我们在苏美尔洪水故事中看到它，我们在《阿特拉哈西斯》（Atrahasis）以及其他美索不达米亚文本中看到它——显然对人们关于气候条件发生变化或带来意想不到的冲击时会发生什么的焦虑留下了巨大的印记。而这些被写下来的原因，是为了将焦虑传达给后代。我的意思是，这就是历史学家所做的。否则你只是在闲聊，
You don't bother committing it to cuneiform tablets, pens and paper. In other types of traditions in the Indic world, into the Sanskrit texts too, the ideas of the gods, a bit like in ancient Greece, are busy having rivalries with each other and choosing which humans to be benign to, again, dating back 4,000 years or so, does speak to the idea that the heavens are seen as a gateway towards punishment and reward for
你不会费心把它刻在泥板上、写在纸笔上。在印度世界的其他类型传统中，在梵文文本中，诸神的概念——有点像古希腊——忙于彼此竞争，并选择对哪些人类仁慈，同样可以追溯到四千年前左右，确实说明了这样一种观点：天堂被视为对良好行为进行惩罚和奖励的门户，
good behavior, and the worry that if you exceed your ecological footprints, you're going to face cataclysms. So I think that the idea of apocalypse closely linked towards exhaustion of resources, climatic stress through floods and through drought, run extremely deep into our psyches and our historical records. Yeah. And Peter, just to follow up on this question of, your book is subtitled An Untold History, just how new these perspectives are. The reason that it's untold is because the scientific evidence wasn't available now. Just looking at a couple of very famous examples of how historians have interpreted the interaction of climate with history. So the 6th century AD, which is a period that you're particularly
而人们担心，如果你超出了生态足迹，你将面临灾难。所以我认为，与资源耗竭、通过洪水和干旱造成的气候压力紧密相连的末日观念，深深植根于我们的心理和历史记录中。是的。彼得，为了顺着这个问题继续探讨——你的书的副标题是“一部未被讲述的历史”，这些观点是多么的新颖。之所以说它未被讲述，是因为以前没有科学证据。现在来看几个非常著名的例子，关于历史学家如何解释气候与历史的相互作用。比如公元 6 世纪，这是一个你特别熟悉的时期。
familiar with. Love the 6th century. It's often said that this is a period that you're particularly familiar with. Love the 6th century. It's often said that this is a period where there's massive cooling, has massive knock-on effects on the Persian Empire, on the Byzantine Empire, on the emergence of Islam, all kinds of things like that. And then the other one is what's called the Little Ice Age, and particularly focused on the 17th century. The idea that there is actually a global ice age a global cooling yeah we've talked about that a lot in this podcast yeah the sort of 30
热爱 6 世纪。人们常说这是一个你特别熟悉的时期。热爱 6 世纪。人们常说这是一个气温急剧下降、对波斯帝国、拜占庭帝国、伊斯兰教的兴起等产生巨大连锁反应的时期。另一个例子就是所谓的“小冰期”，特别聚焦于 17 世纪。这种观点认为，实际上存在着一次全球冰期——全球降温——是的，我们在本播客中讨论过很多次了——某种程度上像三十年战争、
years war the english civil wars all that stuff but also in china the the collapse of imperial structures in china and and in america in africa those two examples are we able now as historians, as scientists, to stress test just what the nature of the interaction of climate is with empires, with frameworks of authority, better than we were, say, 10 years ago, 20 years ago? Okay, so the 6th century, the thing that is most important is not to get hung up on climate on its own. So climate is an important factor, and it's interesting because of the temperature drops. By far, the more important thing is that climate shifts triggered by a series of volcanic eruptions
英国内战之类的东西，但在中国，中国帝制结构的崩溃，以及美洲、非洲……对于这两个例子，我们现在作为历史学家、作为科学家，是否能够比比如 10 年前、20 年前更好、更准确地压力测试气候与帝国、与权力框架相互作用的本质呢？好的，所以对于 6 世纪，最重要的事情是不要过分纠结于气候本身。因此，气候是一个重要因素，它之所以有趣是因为气温骤降。相比之下，远为更重要的是，由一系列火山爆发触发的气候转变——
in the 530s and early 540s. Because you love a volcanic eruption, don't you? You love a volcanic eruption. Well, I'm nervous. They're going off throughout your book. They do go off. Kind of every other page volcano is i will come back we'll come back to volcanoes those volcanic eruptions in the sixth century
在 530 年代和 540 年代初。因为你喜欢火山爆发，对吧？你喜欢火山爆发。嗯，我很紧张。它们贯穿了你的书。它们确实爆发了。差不多每隔一页就有火山——我会回来的，我们回过头来谈火山。6 世纪的那些火山爆发——
by far the most dramatic thing they do is not just um impacting uh atmospheric conditions and reduce crop grain periods which they clearly do and impact belief systems because lots of people can are concerned about punishment from the divine etc etc the thing that's by far the most important is they change pathogen behavior and the pathogen behavior in this particular case is is making plague more virulent and allows the justinianic play to take hold and to decimate i mean it's part of a very frosty conversation between different groups of historians but clearly it's part of a very frosty conversation between different groups of historians, but clearly it's a massive population loss in Europe. And in that sense,
它们所做的最戏剧性的事情，不仅仅是影响大气条件并缩短农作物生长期（它们显然做到了这一点），以及影响信仰体系（因为许多人担心来自神明的惩罚等等），远为最重要的是，它们改变了病原体的行为。在这种特定情况下，病原体的行为使瘟疫更具毒性，并让查士丁尼瘟疫得以立足并大肆蹂躏——我的意思是，这是一场不同历史学家群体之间非常冰冷的对话的一部分——但显然，这是欧洲人口的大量损失。从这个意义上说，
what volcanoes often do is not just that they inject masses of dust into the atmosphere and make it slightly harder to grow things. It's quite often they trigger medical and disease environments to change. And two good examples that parallel what happens in the 6th century is the eruption of Santorini around 1600 BC, where apart from the tsunami it generates that knocks over Crete, the fact that it's a huge detonation, it triggers again, in this particular case, the virulence of the variola virus, which your listeners will know is what lies behind smallpox. And smallpox in the last couple of hundred years before its eradication probably killed about 300 million people just in the 19th and most of the 18th, 19th, 20th centuries alone.
火山爆发通常所做的，不仅是将大量灰尘注入大气并使农作物的生长变得稍微困难一些，它们往往还会引发医疗和疾病环境的变化。与 6 世纪相似的两个好例子是大约公元前 1600 年圣托里尼（Santorini）的爆发，除了它产生并摧毁了克里特岛的海啸之外，由于它是一次巨大的爆炸，它再次——在这种特定情况下——引发了天花病毒（Variola virus）的毒性，听众朋友们会知道，这就是天花背后的病因。而在被消灭前的最后几百年里，仅在 19 世纪以及大部分的 18、19、20 世纪，天花就可能杀死了大约 3 亿人。
So those kinds of things are much more important than a growing season. Likewise, Mount Tambora that, you know, again, that generated the year without the summer and obviously is linked through to... So that's 1816. 1815, the trigger, but the summer of 1816, which, you know, you can, but the summer of 1816, which you can
所以这类事情远比一个生长期更重要。同样，坦博拉火山（Mount Tambora）——你知道的，它再次引发了“无夏之年”，并且显然与……所以那是 1816 年。1815 年是导火索，但 1816 年的夏天，你知道的，你可以——但 1816 年的夏天，你可以把它——
fold into the Peterloo Massacre. You can link through to... Frankenstein. Frankenstein. It's a whole palette you can open up. But one of the things it does that has more implic... Well, it doesn't have to be either or, but creates a general impact is it changes the marine biology of the Bay of Bengal that unlocks and makes cholera take over. And the cholera that then devastates Bengal spreads and you can trace it through the Middle East, through into Russia, into Europe. And so these kinds of things are just all about the natural environment and about how they shift us around rather than just around climatic conditions. But I think we don't necessarily always overlook those. But quite often historians, as you know from your podcast and from your own wonderful work, we tend to specialise in single periods or single regions.
归入彼得卢屠杀（Peterloo Massacre）。你可以把它和……弗兰肯斯坦联系起来。弗兰肯斯坦。你可以打开一整套调色板。但它所做的事情之一，具有更多暗示性——好吧，它不一定是非此即彼的，但它产生了普遍的影响——是它改变了孟加拉湾的海洋生物学，从而解开了枷锁并让霍乱占据了上风。随后蹂躏孟加拉的霍乱蔓延开来，你可以追踪它穿过中东、进入俄罗斯、进入欧洲。因此，这些事情完全是关于自然环境的，是关于它们如何让我们四处腾挪，而不仅仅是围绕着气候条件。但我认为我们并不一定总是忽视这些。但通常情况下，历史学家——正如你们从你们的播客和你们自己的精彩工作中所知——我们往往专注于单一时期或单一地区。
And it's the tying together bigger canvases in detail that I think is the bit that's untold. It's plotting it all out onto a kind of big canvas to take a look at. But so in both these cases, the Delisage and with the Justinianic plagues of the 6th century, I think a lot requires the deftness of the nuance of being able to layer in this new evidence that we have, but to do it in a way that is asking questions. In the case of the Justinianic plague, for example, because we have these new technologies available, there's a group that's worked on a site called Edix Hill in Cambridgeshire that you'll know tom from your from your books uh very well that the black death or the justinianic plague arrives in pelusium of the mouth of the red sea of the gateway to to egypt and then is supposed to spread across the mediterranean that
而将更大的画卷细致地编织在一起，我认为这就是那部分“未被讲述的”历史。将其全部绘制在一张宏大的画卷上进行审视。但是，在这两个案例中——无论是德利萨奇（Delisage）还是 6 世纪的查士丁尼瘟疫——我认为很大程度上需要巧妙的细微差别，能够将我们拥有的这些新证据分层融入其中，但要以提出问题的方式来进行。例如，就查士丁尼瘟疫而言，由于我们有了这些新技术，有一个团队研究了剑桥郡一个叫埃迪克斯希尔（Edix Hill）的遗址，汤姆，你对你的书非常熟悉——黑死病或查士丁尼瘟疫抵达了红海入口处的埃及门户佩鲁修姆（Pelusium），然后应该以那种方式在地中海蔓延开来，
way that's how the historians write about it at the time and you can start to see the deaths being written about in a kind of sequence uh the edicts hill data shows that there's evidence of plague um about four or five years before that episode in North Egypt. So plague is endemic or is existing in not just in England, but in rural England. Right. And so that completely transforms how we should think about how people are traveling, how things are being moved around, what it is that unlocks pestilence and pathogens to make them more virulent. But quite often, emerging infectious diseases are very closely linked to relatively small climatic shifts. So these things, I think, need to be taken in the round.
历史学家当时就是这样写的，你可以开始看到关于死亡人数的记录是按某种顺序书写的——埃迪克斯希尔的数据显示，早在北埃及的那起事件之前大约四到五年，就有瘟疫的证据。所以瘟疫在当时是地方性流行的，或者不仅在英格兰存在，在英国农村也存在。没错。这完全颠覆了我们对人们如何旅行、事物如何被四处运送、是什么解开了瘟疫和病原体的枷锁使其更具毒性的看法。但通常情况下，新发传染病与相对较小的气候变化密切相关。所以我认为，这些事情需要被全面看待。
So just can I come back to the Little Ice Age? Because we've talked about this in previous episodes of this podcast. So for those people who don't know, this is this idea. It's captured brilliantly by Geoffrey Parker in his book, Global Crisis, this 7,000-page book, which covers,page book, which covers a brilliant example of global history. It's talking about famines in China. It's talking about the religious wars in Europe, the witch craze, the enormous political turbulence, all of this sort of stuff and it's linked to the idea that there is a temperature drop of one to two percent or something like that but am i right in thinking that you think that is oversold and that that's the idea that this is all because of climate change and because of a temperature drop is is too well i don't want to say too simplistic well it is too simplistic that is your case isn't it no i mean i'm from all the things that that all my flaws i try not to be a drive-by
所以我能回到小冰期吗？因为我们在本播客之前的单集中讨论过这一点。所以对于那些不知道的人来说，这就是这种观点。杰弗里·帕克（Geoffrey Parker）在他的书《全球危机》（Global Crisis）中完美地捕捉到了这一点，这是一本长达 7000 页的书——一本 7000 页的书，涵盖了全球历史的一个绝佳例子。它讲述了中国的饥荒、欧洲的宗教战争、猎巫狂热、巨大的政治动荡，所有这些乱七八糟的事情，它都与这样一个观点联系在一起：气温下降了百分之一到二左右。但我这样想对吗：你认为这被夸大了，而且这种认为这一切都是因为气候变化和气温下降所致的观点——太——我不想说太简单化——好吧，这确实太简单化了，这就是你的观点，对吧？不，我的意思是，凭着我所有的缺点，我尽量不做别人著作的“免下车刺客”。我的意思是，我认为杰弗里·帕克，这是一本非常棒的书，向他致以崇高的敬意，他凭一己之力提出了诸如小冰期之类的话题。我认为问题在于微观化。这个时期到底是什么时候开始的？
assassin of other people's works. I mean, I think Geoffrey Parker, it's a fantastic book and a huge kudos to raise the subject single-handedly about ideas around things like the Little Ice Age. I think that the problem is going granular. Is it exactly when does this period start? Yeah. What triggers it? And the 17th century makes sense to all of us historians because we like the idea of round numbers like 1600 and 1700 and that may or may not be a reflection of um of periodization so lots of people argue about what exactly that date range is for the little i said should we start it in 1450 should it start in 1600 um and so on so some of it depends on what it is you want to look
是什么引发的？17 世纪对我们所有历史学家来说都说得通，因为我们喜欢像 1600 和 1700 这样整洁的数字，这可能反映也可能不反映分期——所以很多人在争论小冰期的确切日期范围是什么：我们应该从 1450 年开始，还是应该从 1600 年开始，等等。因此，其中一部分取决于你想看什么。
at and also i've been around the block enough times to know sometimes what you put on the cover of a book is about getting people to engage with its content. No, surely not. Or maybe you should be a little bit more generous about what the aims are. The thing that's interesting about Parker's book, which he flags rather than I do, is that this crisis that you mentioned, Dominic, where we have the 30 years war in Europe, death on a profound scale, dislocations all over the world. There are places that are immune from those kinds of problems. And in particular, Japan and the Dutch Republic don't seem to go through those kinds of gateposts of crisis.
而且，我在这个行当里待得够久了，深知有时候你把什么放在书封面上，是为了吸引人们参与其内容。不，当然不会吧。或者也许你应该对这些目标更加慷慨一点。帕克的书有趣的地方在于——是他指出的，而不是我——你提到的这场危机，多米尼克，我们在欧洲经历了三十年战争、深重的死亡、世界各地的动荡。有些地方却能免疫于这类问题。特别是日本和荷兰共和国，似乎没有经历过这些危机门槛。
And that will presumably speak to not about the fact that the climates are slightly different, it speaks to the resilience of the political structures that allow people to navigate crisis. And I think that's more interesting. I mean, as it happens in the course of the late 1580s, 1590s onwards, you have a series of very significant, Tom's favourite again, and mine, volcanic eruptions that do produce very dramatic localised problems, particularly in the Americas. You know, there's one eruption in 1596 in Hunya Putina
这大概说明，问题不在于气候略有不同，而在于政治结构的韧性，是它们让人们能够度过危机。我认为这更有趣。事实上，在 1580 年代末、1590 年代及以后，发生了一系列非常显著的——又是汤姆的最爱，也是我的最爱——火山爆发，这些爆发确实产生了非常剧烈的地方性问题，特别是在美洲。你知道的，1596 年在南美洲的
in South America that is enormous in its scale. And these do produce challenges. And historians, as we all know, lots of the times challenges are navigated. But if you are at that time fighting wars of religion, if you have military expenditure that's soaking up resources, if you have a court, let's say, in China under the Ming dynasty that is too busy with paying money on its eunuchs and its harems and poorly managed, then you find you run into problems. But it doesn't always have to happen that way. So just before we come on to the huge climate apocalypse, ie what we're living now just to row back and say that climate change is not necessarily bad is it because essentially human history happens because we're not living in an ice age would that be an exaggeration well climate change definitely isn't bad so the emergence from an ice age is what enables us to make a podcast because otherwise
休纳普蒂纳（Huaynaputina）发生了一次爆发，规模极其巨大。这些确实带来了挑战。正如我们都知道的那样，历史学家们，很多时候挑战都被克服了。但如果你当时正在进行宗教战争，如果你有消耗资源的军事开支，如果明朝中国的一个朝廷把太多精力花在给太监和后宫花钱上且管理不善，你就会发现自己陷入了困境。但事情并不总是非得那样发展。所以在我们讨论巨大的气候末日——也就是我们现在生活中的情况——之前，为了回溯一下并说气候变化不一定是坏事，对吧？因为从根本上讲，人类历史的发生正是因为我们没有生活在冰期里，这样说会不会太夸张了？嗯，气候变化绝对不是坏事，所以从冰期中走出来，正是让我们能够录制播客的原因，否则
there wouldn't be any history for us to talk about. Climate change, that just means things move around. I mean, history has all changed. So climate is one thing that changes. There are lots of things that change. I don't think that's either good or bad. Clearly, there are winners and losers. I think global warming is a slightly different phenomenon to climate change. I think resource depletion is obviously another challenge. But global warming, I mean, we were in an ice age. Yes. And then we emerged into what is called Holocene, the period in which we're now living, the geological period of time.
就不会有任何历史供我们谈论了。气候变化，那只意味着事物在四处移动。我的意思是，历史已经全部改变了。所以气候是会变化的一件事。还有很多事情在变化。我不认为这非好即坏。显然，有赢家也有输家。我认为全球变暖与气候变化是略有不同的现象。我认为资源耗竭显然是另一个挑战。但全球变暖，我的意思是，我们曾经处于冰期中。是的。然后我们走进了被称为“全新世”（Holocene）的时期，也就是我们现在生活的时期，即地质时间段。
And had the planet not warmed to that extent, it's unlikely that we would have had agriculture, urban societies, whatever. Well, for 99.99% of the world's history, we wouldn't have survived, our species wouldn't have survived in the carbon dioxide envelope that it existed in so we're great beneficiaries of all the serendipitous changes going back four and a half billion years you know without the five great mass extinctions
如果地球没有变暖到那个程度，我们不太可能拥有农业、城市社会，或者其他什么。嗯，在世界历史上 99.99% 的时间里，我们的物种在它曾经存在的二氧化碳包膜中是无法存活的。所以我们是追溯到四5亿年前的所有幸运变化的巨大受益者。你知道的，如果没有过去的五次大灭绝，
of the past we wouldn't be here we're at the long end of a sequence that dates back uh billions of years so i think i think that that should give us a little bit of humility around how narrow our window might be on this planet because as you you know, with your dinosaurs and other interests in the past, Tom, you can be the apex predator for as long as you like, for millions of years, in fact. And I dare say your T-Rexes and beloved predators will survive much, much longer than our species will do, where we're literally a blink in the eye. I mean, our written record, going back to about 3,000 or 4,000 BC, let's call it, so about 5,000 years. In terms of the world's history, that's 0.00001%. So that means, yes, is it bad? It's probably bad if you are poor. It's probably bad
我们就不会在这里。我们处于一个可以追溯到数十亿年前的序列的末端。所以我想，这应该让我们对我们在这个星球上的窗口期有多么狭窄保持一点谦逊。因为正如你——带着你对恐龙和其他过去事物的兴趣，汤姆——你可以做顶级掠食者，你想做多久就做多久，事实上可以持续数百万年。我敢说，你的霸王龙和心爱的掠食者会比我们的物种存活得久得多，而我们在地球历史中仅仅是电光石火的一瞬。我的意思是，我们的文字记录可以追溯到大约公元前 3000 年或 4000 年，我们就叫它 5000 年吧。就世界历史而言，那是 0.00001%。所以这意味着，是的，这很糟糕吗？如果你很穷，这可能很糟糕。如果你
if you are exposed to the tropics and to very substantial temperature rises, which look likely. It's bad if you are, as a government report has produced today, around flooding and coastal flooding on the British Isles, where we have all of our power reactors on the coasts. That probably raises questions about how can you navigate problems, but that doesn't mean you fail. It just means recognising that you're probably in for a slightly slightly bumpy bit of fast bowling and uh you can you can handle again as you know tom from your distinguished cricketing career you can handle uh youthful uh young bowlers throwing i was going to say young boys but you know throwing balls at you faster than you can go and you can hit them for six as the world knows when when that echoed the explosion of Tambora. To be clear, Tom Six was against a child.
暴露在热带地区并面临看起来很有可能的显著气温上升，这可能很糟糕。正如今天政府发布的一份关于不列颠群岛洪水和海岸洪水的报告所显示的那样，如果我们所有的核反应堆都建在海岸线上，这可能很糟糕。这大概会引发一些问题：你该如何应对这些问题？但这并不意味着你失败了。这只是意味着你认识到，你可能要经历一段稍微有些颠簸的快速投球期，而你能够——正如你所知，汤姆，凭着你卓越的板球生涯——你能够应对——我本来想说是年轻男孩，但你知道的——那些以你无法想象的速度向你扔来的球，你可以把它们击出六分界外，正如全世界都知道的那样，当那回荡着坦博拉火山的爆发时。需要明确的是，汤姆打出的六分是针对一个孩子的。
I just want that absolutely on record. That's right, isn't it, Peter? It's the shot that went around the world. I wasn't there, so I can't, I can't, I've only seen the photos. But no, I think that it's how do you handle the challenges coming towards you? And right now, our problem is, it's a multiple set of combinations. Okay, Peter, hold on, hold on. We'll come to the problems that we're facing now a bit later.
我只想把这绝对记录在案。是这样的，对吧，彼得？这是轰动全球的一击。我当时不在场，所以我不能——我只能看到照片。不，我认为关键在于你如何应对向你袭来的挑战？而现在，我们的问题是，这是一组多重的组合。好了，彼得，等等，等等。我们稍后再谈我们现在面临的问题。
I just want to stick now to the idea that global, not just climate change, but global warming can be potentially a positive. And that the fact that the Ice Age ended was a kind of broad positive, I would say. I mean, that seems to be the implication of your book. But also that there have been... So you... The Roman warm period. What's the Roman warm period, Peter?
我只想现在坚持这样一个观点：全球变暖——不仅仅是气候变化，还有全球变暖——有可能是一件积极的事情。冰期的结束在宏观上是一种积极的事情，我想我会这么说。我的意思是，这似乎是你书中的暗示。而且也曾有过……所以你……罗马温暖期。什么是罗马温暖期，彼得？
It does sound like... I quite like a Roman warm period where we're getting snowfall. I mean, it sounds great, doesn't it? I mean, who wouldn't enjoy a Roman warm period? Or indeed, a medieval climate anomaly. I'd prefer the Roman warm period. No question.
听起来确实……我挺喜欢罗马温暖期的，我们有降雪。我的意思是，听起来很棒，对吧？我的意思是，谁会不享受罗马温暖期呢？或者甚至是中世纪气候异常期。我更喜欢罗马温暖期。毫无疑问。
No question. All the Romans get into it under their duvets. What is it what period are we talking about so almost exactly the moment where um augustus or octavius as he was knocked over egypt for the next 250 years it just so happens that climate conditions globally are very stable we're absent of the big volcanic eruptions uh there's no sort of major solar activities that are unusual and there are no anomalies. And so it means that the Romans are very lucky in the world that they're building outwards, that there's
毫无疑问。所有的罗马人都钻进他们的羽绒被里享受它。我们在谈论什么时期？几乎就是在奥古斯都或屋大维为接下来的 250 年击溃埃及的那一刻，全球的气候条件恰好非常稳定，没有发生大型火山爆发，也没有任何异常的重大太阳活动，没有任何异常现象。这意味着罗马人在他们向外建设的世界里非常幸运，有
predictable levels of supply available. And that is, on its own, not enough to explain the success of the Roman Empire, but it's an important factor. And one of the things I write about in the book is thinking around the things that I'm interested in Rome. It's not just the great emperors and the political acts. It's as Rome starts to grow as a city, how do you feed a city like that? How do you actually get grain from A to B? So you need warm conditions that are able, stable conditions that can... But it's not just the climate. You need to have those baths of Caracalla. You need to bring trees from a long, long way away. And what are the logistics of doing those kinds of things? And yeah, sure.
可预测的供应水平。单凭这一点还不足以解释罗马帝国的成功，但这是一个重要因素。我在书中写到的事情之一，就是思考我所感兴趣的罗马。不仅仅是伟大的皇帝和政治行为。当罗马开始发展成为一个城市时，你如何养活这样一个城市？你实际上是如何将粮食从 A 点运到 B 点的？所以你需要温暖的条件能够——稳定的条件能够——但这不仅仅是气候。你需要那些卡拉卡拉浴场。你需要从很远很远的地方运来树木。做这些事情的物流是怎样的？是的，当然。
I understand that, Peter, but we're focusing on climate in this episode. Oh, yes. Rather than trees. Rather than my book. Yeah, okay. Okay. I'm here to serve. I got you.
我明白，彼得，但我们在这一集中重点关注的是气候。哦，是的。而不是树木。而不是我的书。好吧，好吧。我是来效劳的。我懂了。
Yeah, okay. Got you. So just sticking to the climate. Oh, the climate stuff. Yeah. So the salient thing about the Roman warm period is that it is also stable, say, in China. Correct. So that is kind of interesting because it suggests that there is a kind of global, I mean, can we say the same
好吧，明白了。那就只谈气候。哦，气候。是的。所以罗马温暖期显著的一点在于，它在中国等地也是稳定的。没错。所以这就有点意思了，因为这表明存在一种全球性的——我的意思是，我们能说同样的
about what's happening in Central America as well, can't we? That these are conditions that prevail around the globe. Would that be right? So what we call the Roman warm period could also be the Han warm period. Broadly, globally, this is a stable period. But there are pockets of change that are not, you know, things don't just work as a kind of everybody's happy and temperatures just stay stable. But in terms of the variation, it's relatively modest. And where that starts to change in the middle of the third century, in the 230s, 240s onwards,
我们也可以谈谈中美洲正在发生的事情，对吧？这些是在全球各地普遍存在的状况。这样说对吗？所以我们所说的罗马暖期也可以是汉朝暖期。大体上、在全球范围内，这是一个稳定的时期。但也有一些局势发生变化的地区，事情并不是说大家都很开心，然后温度就一直保持稳定。但就气候变化而言，它是相对温和的。而这种状况在公元三世纪中期开始发生变化，在公元230年代、240年代及以后，
you then see a series of high levels of returns of those kind of unstable conditions. And then you have a period where you have 25 Roman emperors on the throne in a 40-year period. You have 65 would-be emperors trying to take power. And those dislocations correlate quite closely with disruption. And the problem is, again, it's not that because it rained a lot, or there was volcanic eruptions, or you couldn't grow so much crops. It's that small chinks in the wall can bring the whole thing tumbling down. So small individual problems can magnify. So one bat in Wuhan, and the whole world shuts down and 10 million people die. And that process of understanding those fragilities of interconnectivities are important. So it's the same thing along the Silk Roads. It's the same thing in Mesoamerica. When a single point
随后你会看到一连串高度反复出现的这类不稳定状况。接着，你在40年里经历了25位罗马皇帝登基。有65位潜在的皇帝试图夺取权力。这些混乱与社会动荡密切相关。问题再次在于，这并不是因为雨水过多、火山爆发，或者农作物减产。而是墙壁上的微小裂缝可能导致整个大厦轰然倒塌。因此，微小的个别问题会被放大。正如武汉的一只蝙蝠，就能让全世界停摆并导致1000万人死亡。理解这种互联互通的脆弱性的过程是很重要的。丝绸之路沿线也是如此，中美洲也是如此。当某个单一环节
fails for whatever reason, because of disease, because of corrupt leadership, because of a random enemy that pops up and knocks you over, then the whole house of cards comes tumbling down quite quickly. Okay. And so that goes back to what we were talking about at the beginning, how difficult it is to identify climate change specifically as an agent of change and transformation. Yeah, so that's a problem if you're making a podcast, but it's not a problem if you're writing a book that isn't saying that. All right, we should take a break at this moment. And Peter can go away to consider his behaviour, Tom, and the listeners can return to find him a chastened, and let's hope, a better man. We'll be back in a second.
由于某种原因而失效——无论是由于疾病、腐败的领导层，还是由于突然出现并把你击倒的某个随机敌人——整个纸牌屋就会相当快地轰然倒塌。好吧。这就回到了我们一开始讨论的话题，即要把气候变化明确认定为变革和转型的动因是多么困难。是的，如果你在制作播客，这是个问题，但如果你在写一本并不持这种观点的书，这就不是问题了。好了，我们现在该休息一下了。汤姆，彼得可以去反思一下他的行为了，而听众们回来时会发现他是一个受过惩罚、而且我们希望变得更好的人。我们马上回来。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《这就是娱乐》。这是你获取娱乐新闻、评论以及少许八卦的每周必看节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目并提前购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
On a cad's chariot roads grew nothing but the whaling plant. Moreover, on its canal boat towpaths and landings, no human being walks because of the wild goats, vermin, snakes and mountain scorpions. The plains where grew the heart soothing plants grew nothing but the reed of tears. Terrifying. So, Tom, that is terrifying. That's again more of the curse of Akkad which was slightly debunked i'm sorry to say in the first half of that episode by peter frankman a very distinguished guest who tom is desperately trying to control as though on a leash or something it doesn't normally do with
在阿卡德的战车路上，除了鲸鱼草什么也没有长出来。此外，在其运河船只的纤道和码头上，由于有野山羊、害虫、蛇和山。蝎子，没有人行走。生长着舒心草的平原上，除了眼泪芦苇什么也没长。太可怕了。所以，汤姆，这太可怕了。这再次体现了阿卡德的诅咒，我很抱歉地说，这一诅咒在那期节目的前半部分被彼得·弗兰克潘稍微揭穿了，他是一位非常杰出的嘉宾，汤姆正拼命地试图控制他，就像拴着狗链什么的，汤姆通常不会对
that guess this is some internal cricket team politics i don't understand no it's not no it's it's it's rather like with Willy Dalrymple. Yeah. Fenton rushing off and attacking deer in Regent's Park. But I don't think he is being very Fenton-like, actually. I think you're being a bit harsh on him. Peter, let's take the story towards our present moment. So the Industrial Revolution beginning, as everybody knows, in shropshire does that mark a definitive new chapter indeed a new book in in this story because of the massive impact of man-made climate change not just locally but globally is that fair to say yes i think that the the injection of uh fossil fuels
那个嘉宾这样做，这是某种我不懂的板球内部政治吗？不，不是的。不，这，这，这有点像威利·达尔林普尔。是的，芬顿冲出去攻击摄政公园里的鹿。但我认为他表现得不是很像芬顿，实际上。我觉得你对他的要求有点严苛。彼得，让我们把故事推进到我们当前的时刻。那么，正如大家所知，工业革命始于什罗普郡，这标志着这个故事中一个明确的新篇章，甚至是一本新书吗？因为人为气候变化不仅对当地而且对全球产生了巨大影响，这样说公平吗？是的，我认为，由于工业革命，特别是内燃机，
into our atmosphere as a result of the industrial revolution and particularly the combustion engine clearly generates lots of benefits and lots of wins. The energy revolution is an important one that redistributes global powers as well and rights. There are lots of ways in which one can look at this in a positive way, but there are ecological and environmental consequences for that that I think are really quite tricky and complicated. But the challenge wasn't in 1700. It's been in much more recent times. So, for example, about 85% of the fossil fuel has been burnt since the end of the Second World War by humans, and about 50% since I did my A-levels in 1989. So it's the scale of change in the last three or four decades that's been most dramatic.
将化石燃料注入我们的大气层，显然带来了很多好处和赢面。能源革命也是一场重要的革命，它重新分配了全球权力和权利。人们可以从很多积极的角度来看待这个问题，但它带来的生态和环境后果，我认为确实非常棘手和复杂。但挑战并不是在1700年出现的。而是在更近的时期。例如，大约85%的化石燃料是自第二次世界大战结束以来由人类燃烧的，大约50%是我在1989年参加高级水平考试以来燃烧的。因此，在过去的三十或四十年里，这种变化的规模是最戏剧性的。
But again, if one looks at the natural environment and the transformations too, the ways in which we have globalized, partly as a result of the Columbian Exchange, partly as a result of empire, partly as a result of the world tying together and trying to find the best prices and the best goods and shipping them and the new technologies that have allowed people to communicate like us quicker, cheaper, better than ever before, has downsides too. And I think it's not, again, it's not an either or, it's that they both come hand in hand. And one of those problems is about the velocity of consumption patterns that means that we can exploit the natural environment faster than it can replenish. And again, that is partly a result of improvements in communications, transport, travel, sciences, technologies.
但同样，如果人们审视自然环境及其转变，我们全球化的方式——部分是哥伦布大交换的结果，部分是帝国的结果，部分是世界紧密相连并试图找到最优惠的价格和最好的商品并将其运送出去的结果，以及使人们能够比以往更快、更便宜、更好地进行交流的新技术——也有其消极的一面。我认为，这同样不是非此即彼的关系，而是这两者齐头并进。其中一个问题是消费模式的速度，这意味着我们剥离自然环境的速度超过了它恢复的速度。同样，这也是通信、交通、旅行、科学和技术不断改进的结果。
That leaves us in a world where things don't necessarily have to be precarious, but the challenge is if you're living, like back in Akkad, if you're living on the edge of your environmental envelope, it doesn't take a lot to tip you over to not be able to feed everybody. It doesn't take a lot to tip you over to create proper problems that could then ignite social and political unrest. But most of the time, that doesn't happen. Most of the time, in the last 30, 40 years, apart from a few obvious hotspots, we tend to get on quite well. I think that now the thing I'm as worried about about global warming is that we look like
这给我们留下的世界是：事物不一定非得处于岌岌可危的境地，但挑战在于，如果你像阿卡德那样生活在环境边缘，那么不需要太多的催化剂，就会让你陷入无法养活所有人的境地。不需要太多的催化剂，就会制造出真正的问题，从而点燃社会和政治动荡。但大多数时候，这种情况并没有发生。在大多数情况下，在过去的30、40年里，除了少数几个明显的冲突热点外，我们往往相处得相当融洽。我认为，现在让我对全球变暖同样感到担忧的是，我们看起来
we're living in a world of quite deep fragmentation anyway and here in europe and you know with uh helen thompson for example my colleague at cambridge who's written so well about this that being on the show yeah she's been on the show that's right energy energy inefficiency in europe and the lack of planning into clean and green technologies isn't just about in the environment it means that we are in hock to what putin's whims might be or whims in the Middle East and those who produce the energy needs that we have. And the problem is adaptation. So again, the warming problem could be solved on its own. But when you have supply shocks, cost of living, inflationary crises, if governments don't solve those problems, then there is a sort of set of
无论如何都生活在一个相当深刻分裂的世界里，比如在欧洲，你知道的，有我剑桥的同事海伦·汤普森，她对这一点写得非常好，她曾上过节目。是的，她上过节目，没错。欧洲的能源效率低下以及缺乏对清洁和绿色技术的规划，不仅仅关乎环境，这意味着我们受制于普京的心血来潮，或是中东以及那些满足我们能源需求者的心血来潮。而问题在于适应能力。所以，同样地，变暖问题可以单独解决。但是，当你面临供应冲击、生活成本危机、通货膨胀危机时，如果政府不解决这些问题，那么就会有一系列
predictable gateways that you run through that we can recognise from history, but it's very hard to guess which ones might come first. So going all the way back to Akkad, you have people feeling that the heavens are out of joint, that a realm that had previously been stable and prosperous is now faced with massive shocks. And this is, as we've been exploring, a kind of recurrent anxiety that the heavens are sitting in judgment on us. Is what we are facing now, I mean, is that just another kind of example of that anxiety, one that we will move on from? Or is this qualitatively more perilous? Are we properly facing apocalypse? Well, you know, Paul Ehrlich wrote a book called
我们可以从历史中识别出来的、可预测的关卡，但很难猜出哪一个可能会先到来。因此，追溯到阿卡德，人们会觉得天象失常，一个曾经稳定繁荣的王国现在面临着巨大的冲击。正如我们一直在探讨的那样，这是一种反复出现的焦虑，即上天正在对我们进行审判。我们现在所面临的，我的意思是，这只是这种焦虑的另一种表现吗？一种我们终将走出来的焦虑？还是说这种焦虑在性质上更加危险？我们是否真的面临着末日？好吧，你知道，保罗·埃里希在20世纪60年代写过一本书叫
Population Bomb in the 1960s that said, you know, we're already way beyond our abilities to feed people. And we're looking at 10s of millions of starvation deaths in the next decade. And that proved to be totally wrong. So lots of people have warned about the doom and gloom. So, I don't particularly want to add my name to the list of people who are wrong about things. But I think I would defer to my friends and colleagues who work in biological sciences around biodiversity loss. So if we forget about humans and our problems for a moment, it's the collapse of amphibian species, of birds, of the changes to the mammalian world and of plant life that are not uniform. You know, there are winners and losers in those equations. But clearly we're going through a process that some of my very distinguished
《人口炸弹》，书中说，我们养活人们的能力已经远远超出了极限。我们预计在下一个十年里会有数千万人因饥饿而死。事实证明这完全是错误的。因此，很多人都发出过末日和悲观的警告。所以，我并不是很想把自己的名字加到那些预测错误的人的名单中。但我认为我会听取我的朋友和同事的意见，他们从事与生物多样性丧失相关的生物科学工作。因此，如果我们暂时忘掉人类和我们的问题，那就是两栖动物物种、鸟类的崩溃，哺乳动物世界和植物生命的变化，这些都不是均匀发生的。你知道，这些方程式中既有赢家也有输家。但很显然，我们正在经历一个过程，我的一些非常杰出的
colleagues call already we're going through a sixth mass extinction. And the difference about this one compared to previous five is that it's already much faster than those dramatic ones of comets hitting the asteroids, hitting Chichiclub in Mexico and volcanic eruptions that played out over the course of thousands of years. But the rate of change, I think, of biodiversity loss and of pollinators and so on does reach what, again, are being referred to in the sciences as cascade events, where you have a whole series of things that keep getting worse and worse. It's not just, is it going to be 40 degrees this summer? we'll be able to play cricket and so on, which, you know, I don't say that to be flippant. But you can go through these
同事称我们已经在经历第六次大灭绝。与前五次大灭绝相比，这次的不同之处在于，它已经比那些戏剧性的事件要快得多，比如彗星和小行星撞击墨西哥的希克蘇魯伯，以及历时数千年的火山爆发。但我认为，生物多样性丧失和授粉媒介等变化的速度，已经达到了科学界所说的级联事件（cascade events），即一系列情况不断恶化。这不仅仅是说，今年夏天会达到40度吗？我们还能打板球等等，你知道的，我这样说并不是为了轻率。但是你可以经历这些
gateways of Antarctic ice melts and of sea level rises that don't happen over the course of a year or two. But they do over the course of a decade or two. And you can't plan fast enough to be thinking about what those might be to both mitigate and also to be aware of what some of the worst scenarios are. So for example, the head of Lloyd's Insurance, one of the biggest insurers in the world, has been saying in the last couple of months, that essentially Florida is uninsurable now from a commercial point of view, because of the sea level rises, the tornado seasons, the level of damage that have been done in the last few years, that the premiums are too high. And I think that that should make wherever you sit in the world, sit up and think we are living in a world that is changing really dramatically fast environmentally, as well as all the political stuff that we see
南极冰层融化和海平面上升的关卡，这些不是在一两年内发生的，而是在一二十年内发生的。你无法制定足够快的计划来考虑这些可能是什么，既为了缓解危机，也为了意识到一些最糟糕的情景可能是什么。例如，世界最大的保险公司之一劳合社的负责人最近几个月一直在说，从商业角度来看，佛罗里达州基本上已经无法投保了，因为海平面上升、龙卷风季节以及过去几年造成的破坏程度，保费太高了。我认为，无论你身处世界的哪个角落，这都应该让你警醒，并认为我们生活在一个环境变化极其剧烈的世界里，同时还有我们所看到的各种政治问题，
that has its own existential challenges. You quote a senior investment banker last summer, who said, who cares if Miami is six meters underwater in 10 years, in 100 years, what happens to the planet in year seven is actually irrelevant to our loan book. I think he was saying that slightly tongue in cheek, wasn't he? But it does express an attitude that perhaps ties into very ancient ideas that greed and heedlessness will be punished by the gods. Well, I've got a report commissioned by BAFTA in my book around uses of words on TV. But they measure the number of times that the words global warming
它们有着各自的生存挑战。你去年夏天引用了一位高级投资银行家的的话，他说，如果迈阿密在10年、100年后被淹没在水下6米，谁会在乎呢，第七年地球会发生什么，其实和我们的贷款账簿无关。我想他当时说这话时有点半开玩笑，不是吗？但它确实表达了一种态度，也许这与非常古老的观念相契合，即贪婪和粗心大意将受到神的惩罚。好吧，我手里有一份英国电影学院奖（BAFTA）在我书中委托撰写的关于电视用词的报告。他们统计了过去两年中电视和广播里提到“全球变暖”
and climate change have been mentioned in the last two years on TV and radio. And I think climate change, if I'm right, mentioned about 3,000 times. The word dog is mentioned 110,000 times. Cheese, about 130, 000 times and that would tell me that the the way in which we were informed as i when i was growing up when we were growing up uh you know we were much more closely connected to acid rain and to chernobyl and these kind of challenges but i think that the level of preparation is out of sync with the level of discourse around
和“气候变化”这两个词的次数。我想“气候变化”这个词，如果我没记错的话，大约被提到了3,000次。“狗”这个词被提到了110,000次。“奶酪”大约被提到了130,000次，这告诉我，我们过去接受的信息，就像我成长的时候，我们成长的时候，你知道的，我们与酸雨和切尔诺贝利以及这类挑战的联系要紧密得多，但我认为准备水平与围绕我们所面临问题的讨论水平并不成正比
what we're facing and you know our next generations have got a real challenge coming towards them. And I think one of the things that's quite worrying about this is that when you see young people and the students who come through my university who are carrying quite high levels of debt, unless they're from high income families, probably unlikely to be able to afford
我们的下一代将面临真正的挑战。我认为对此相当令人担忧的事情之一是，当你看到年轻人和来到我大学的学生时，他们背负着相当高的债务水平，除非他们来自高收入家庭，否则不太可能负担得起
to get on the property ladder for a while. Job ladder looks extremely precarious. They've seen the shenanigans going on in the world of politics for you know years now whatever your political persuasions uh not just in the uk in fact and that lack of confidence in democratic um abilities to solve problems combined with climate has produced some real worries i mean there's some work commissioned just at the end of 2022 that says that 60% of people under the age of 45 in liberal democracies don't believe that regular elections are an essential part of a functioning democracy and would pick a strong man who can solve
在一段时间内登上房地产阶梯。就业阶梯看起来极其岌岌可危。多年来，你看到政坛上发生的种种闹剧，无论你的政治倾向如何，不仅在英国，事实上，对民主解决问题能力的缺乏信心与气候问题结合在一起，产生了一些真正的担忧。我的意思是，20世纪20年代末刚委托完成的一项研究表明，自由民主国家中45岁以下的人中有60%不相信定期选举是运作良好的民主国家必不可少的一部分，并且会选择一个能够解决问题的强人，
problems. That's the phrase used, strong man who can solve problems, rather than looking to solve things through democracies. And for my generation, our generation... Peter, your moment has come. My moment, here I come, stride to the middle and hit a double hundred. Now, I think that those do start to unweave a set of problems that do have echoes back to Naram-Sin.
用的是这个词，能解决问题的强人，而不是指望通过民主来解决问题。对于我这一代人，我们这一代人……彼得，你的时刻到了。我的时刻，我来啦，大步走到球场中央，击出一个双百。现在，我认为这些确实开始解开了一系列与纳拉姆辛相呼应的问题。
And there are winners in those equations. Naram-Sin was able to take advantage of the so-called curse to make himself even stronger than he had been before. And inequalities tend to sharpen and get more divisive. Societies tend to become more unequal, more top-heavy. And Peter, is there another historical angle to this, which is that one of the things that makes the challenge hard to confront is that it's become entangled with the
这些方程式中也有赢家。纳拉姆辛能够利用所谓的诅咒，让自己比以前变得更加强大。而不平等往往会加剧，变得更具分裂性。社会往往会变得更加不平等、更加头重脚轻。彼得，这其中还有另一个历史角度吗？那就是，使这一挑战难以面对的原因之一是，它已经与
legacy of history in a different way, which is the legacy of empire and a sense that there needs to be a kind of rebalancing. So you can argue that one great obstacle to resolving this sort of climate crisis is the fact there are lots and lots of people, hundreds of millions of people in China and India who think the West is now being hypocritical. They kicked us for years. They had all the benefits of this, and now they want to deny those benefits to us. Doesn't the legacy of history therefore make it more difficult to resolve because of the experience of empire and the reaction against empire?
历史的遗产以一种不同的方式纠缠在一起，也就是帝国的遗产以及一种需要重新平衡的感觉。因此，你可以争辩说，解决这种气候危机的一个巨大障碍是，中国和印度有成千上万、数以亿计的人认为西方现在是虚伪的。他们踢了我们好多年。他们从中获得了所有的好处，现在他们却想剥夺我们的这些好处。因此，由于帝国的经验以及对帝国的反弹，历史遗产难道不是使问题更难解决了吗？
Well, look, I mean, again, it's something you've covered and both have written about. So, I mean, I think that in that context, probably my own line would be, I mean, obviously that's a factor, empire in the past, but it's also that over the last 30 years, you know, factories across the rich world were devolved and parked in parts of the world where labour costs were much lower, and environmental standards were much lower. And so today, 496 of the world's 500 most polluted cities are in Asia. And I think it stands to reason that we're the great beneficiaries, not because of
好吧，看，我的意思是，这也是你涉猎过并且两人都写过的话题。所以，我的意思是，在那种情况下，我自己的看法可能是，很明显这是一个因素，过去的帝国，但也是因为在过去30年里，你知道的，富裕世界的工厂被外包并安置在劳动力成本和环境标准低得多的地区。因此，今天，世界上500个污染最严重的城市中有496个在亚洲。我认为这不言而喻，我们是巨大的受益者，不是因为
what ancestors did 500 years ago and long British history. But the reason why flat screen TVs and laptops cost what they do and don't cost more is because they're not made in Stoke-on-Trent, or they're not made in Cornwall, but they're made in Sichuan province. And I think that it's not unreasonable to think that the people who have taken the environmental costs of the last 30 years and are most stressed, probably there should be some form of way in which we are able to recognise what those levels of commitment are. So we in the West have done quite well in the last 30 years of reducing our emissions. We've done quite well in recycling. Lots we can do better. But we've had a head start
500年前祖先做过的事以及漫长的英国历史。而是平板电视和笔记本电脑之所以是这个价格而不是更贵，是因为它们不是在特伦特河畔斯托克制造的，也不是在康沃尔制造的，而是在四川省制造的。我认为，认为那些承担了过去30年环境成本并且压力最大的人应该得到某种形式的认可，这并非不合理，这样我们才能认识到这些承诺的水平。所以在过去的30年里，我们在西方在减少排放方面做得相当不错。我们在回收利用方面做得相当不错。我们还有很多可以做得更好的地方。但我们抢占了先机
in all of that. And I think it's not that let's now wag our finger at India, China and everywhere else. It's we're all in this together. There are not that many themes in history that are truly global, but climate is obviously one of them. And so the challenge of being able to factor in what our contribution should be. I mean, if you ask an economic historian like me, you'd say you've got to be prepared for higher costs. And that's the way to try to clean things up. You've got to be willing to say, I will take a longer view, which means that I can't just have a pair of jeans that cost four quid, not just environmental conditions, but also the ESG, the social ways in which that has a cost but ethical ethical buying an ethical investment is something
在所有这些方面。我认为这并不是说现在我们要对印度、中国和其他任何地方摇手指。而是我们都在同一条船上。历史上真正具有全球性的主题其实并不多，但气候显然是其中之一。因此，能够将我们的贡献因素考虑进去的挑战。我的意思是，如果你问像我这样的经济史学家，你会说你必须做好承受更高成本的准备。这就是试图清理环境的方法。你必须愿意说，我会采取长远眼光，这意味着我不能只买一条4英镑的牛仔裤，这不仅关乎环境条件，还关乎ESG、产生社会成本的社会方式，但道德采购和道德投资是你
that you can do if you're wealthy but you can go hand in hand if you work out a corporate and probably in today's world in my day job that's not related to climate it's that lack of dialogue that is brutal i think particularly with china but in other parts of the world too that partly because the political narrative of kicking the west or the west sort of demanding um submission or demanding support on things like Ukraine. But you know, Putin has exploited that extremely successfully. In his speech he gave in the Kremlin a couple of weeks ago, he said, look, the West has pumped in $150 billion into Ukraine, these are his numbers, and has only put $60 billion into the developing world. So whose interests are really being
如果你富有的话，你可以做到这一点，但如果你制定了企业战略，也许在当今世界的我的日常工作中，这与气候无关，那种缺乏对话的现象是残酷的，我认为特别是在中国，但在世界的其他地方也是如此，部分是因为抨击西方的政治叙事，或者是西方某种程度上要求屈服，或者要求在乌克兰等问题上给予支持。但你知道，普京非常成功地利用了这一点。他在几周前在克里姆林宫发表的演讲中说，看，西方已经向乌克兰注入了1500亿美元，这些是他的数字，而对发展中国家的投入只有600亿美元。那么究竟是谁的利益在真正被
protected? And, you? And I think everybody around the world takes Putin with a bit of a pinch of salt, but those words are very carefully chosen to the 85% of the world's population who don't live in Europe and the West. Well, you have some stupefying statistics on the imbalance between wealthy nations, their contribution to climate change, and those who are not wealthy. So you say that New York City uses more energy than all of sub-Saharan Africa put together, that the world's largest institutional user of petroleum and the single largest institutional producer of greenhouse gases in the world is the US Department of Defense. And you were talking about cheap fashion,
保护呢？而且，你？我想世界上的每个人对普京的话都半信半疑，但这些话是经过精心挑选的，说给占世界人口85%、不住在欧洲和西方的人听的。好吧，关于富裕国家与财富较少国家之间在气候变化贡献上的失衡，你有一些令人瞠目结舌的统计数据。比如你说，纽约市使用的能源比整个撒哈拉以南非洲加起来还要多；世界上石油的最大机构用户、也是全球温室气体单一最大机构生产者是美国国防部。你刚刚谈到了廉价时尚，
and you say that the fashion industry as a whole is estimated to contribute around 10% of global greenhouse gas emissions, more than the aviation and shipping industries combined. Well, making a pair of jeans takes 7,500 litres of water. That's enough for a single human to drink water for seven years. And it's partly a lack of education. We don't really know that, never really think about that. And I think what good history can do is to flag some of these things where if you stop and get your underlining pen and think, I didn't quite understand
你说据估计，整个时尚产业贡献了全球约10%的温室气体排放，超过了航空业和航海业的总和。好吧，制作一条牛仔裤需要7,500升水。这足够一个人喝七年水了。这部分是因为缺乏教育。我们并不真正知道这一点，也从没真正想过这一点。我认为优秀的历史可以做到的事情是指出其中的一些事情，如果你停下来拿起下划线笔思考，我以前并不完全理解
that the fashion and textile industry is something that has a bigger imprint or that some of the winds, in fact, I mean, there's a study done by some very clever scholars that the contrails that are left by planes flying in the sky, that a very modest correction can reduce the environmental damage
时尚和纺织工业的影响更大，或者某些赢面，事实上，我的意思是，一些非常聪明的学者做过一项研究，飞机在空中飞行时留下的凝结尾迹，只需进行非常适度的修正就可以减少环境破坏
that is due by 80% at more or less cost neutral basis. But it requires the modelling. And also, I'm very excited to read that it's been shown that cattle can be trained to control their micturation reflex and use a latrine for urination with significant environmental and climatic benefits. So that's an exciting... Yeah, that's not my own research. But you know, thank God there are people trying to work out,
由于成本大体持平，这一比例可降低80%。但这需要建模。而且，我非常高兴地读到，有研究表明可以训练牛来控制其排尿反射，并使用厕所进行排尿，这具有显著的环境和气候效益。所以这是一个令人兴奋的……是的，这不是我自己的研究。但谢天谢地，有人在努力弄清楚，
I mean, again, we know that cattle and ruminants are a huge part of the problem in terms of methane production. Obviously, the beef is a massively heavy footprint in terms of its demands on soil and above us forest clearance. So to try to find a way to reduce that would seem to be a very positive way of spending taxpayer money on research that might make a difference. And so we can laugh at these kinds of discoveries. But I dare say that there are some people who would think that that's maybe better spent than looking at French revolutionary poetry, through the lens of whatever you might be looking at French revolutionary poetry. And, you know, I think that the ways in which we do need to try to think quite creatively
我的意思是，再次强调，我们知道牛反刍动物在甲烷产生方面是问题的一个巨大部分。很明显，牛肉在其对土壤和上方森林砍伐的需求方面具有巨大的足迹。因此，试图找到一种减少这种情况的方法，似乎是将纳税人的钱花在可能会带来改变的研究上的非常积极的方式。所以我们可以嘲笑这类发现。但我敢说，有些人会认为这可能比通过你可能用来研究法国革命诗歌的某种视角来研究法国革命诗歌要好。而且，你知道，我认为我们确实需要进行非常富有创造性的思考
start with ideas that may seem slightly startling and slightly strange, but we do have quite a series of problems to solve. And getting on with that would seem to be quite a good idea. For such a potentially bleak subject, you're quite optimistic, aren't you? Because on this podcast, long've long time listeners will know that the the sandbrook rule of history is you should eat your neighbors before they eat you but but you definitely don't take that view do you're very miss world you know let's all be great pals we're all friends you know lovers in the air i'm gonna print that out miss world yeah
从可能看起来有点惊人和有点奇怪的想法开始，但我们确实有一系列的问题需要解决。着手解决这些问题似乎是个相当不错的主意。对于一个潜在的凄凉主题，你相当乐观，不是吗？因为在这个播客中，老听众都会知道，桑德布鲁克的历史规律是：在你的邻居吃掉你之前吃掉他们。但是，你绝对不持这种观点，对吧？你非常“世界小姐”风格，你知道的，让我们都成为好伙伴，我们都是朋友，你知道的，空气中弥漫着爱意，我要把这句话打印出来，世界小姐，是的。
okay uh but but you but you are quite optimistic aren't you you do think we have the capacity to overcome these challenges. I mean, you talk a lot about the resilience. You emphasize the resilience of states. You mentioned the Dutch Republic and Japan during the 70th century, or even ACAD. Do you think that resilience will be there in the next few centuries? Well, like I said, I think that the world keeps on spinning. If you're going to bet against that then you know then then i suggest the roman warm period and getting your duvet and finding a
好吧，呃，但是，但是你相当乐观，不是吗？你的确认为我们有能力克服这些挑战。我的意思是，你经常谈论韧性。你强调国家的韧性。你提到了17世纪的荷兰共和国和日本，甚至是阿卡德。你认为这种韧性会在接下来的几个世纪里存在吗？好吧，就像我说的，我认为世界仍在继续旋转。如果你要跟这个唱反调，那么，你知道，那我建议罗马暖期，然后拿上你的羽绒被，找一个
nice quiet burrow to bury yourself in is not a bad idea i think betting against human ingenuity uh is is really bleak you know thinking that we are going through a point where we might all be out of all existence and live in a kind of post-apocalyptic world sooner than later um you know i think it is the the existential side of that is so profound that i think uh you know it is also dangerous to talk to predict the the doom and gloom i mean as it happens those who've done that before me have all got it wrong so yeah if you're going to bet against the house you might as well think that uh you might as well think that there are ways in which we might nudge things forward and improve things. And for all of the terrible horrors of history that you've covered in your podcast, you know, from the Holocaust, through the Second World War, through the trenches of the First World War, through the 17th century, through Justinianic plague, Black Death, you know, the world, even with 50% population losses in some of these cases in the 13th, in the 14th century, for example, you know,
舒适安静的洞穴把自己埋起来，这倒也不是个坏主意。我认为与人类的智慧唱反调，真的是很悲凉的，你知道，认为我们正经历着这样一个时刻，即我们可能很快就会彻底灭绝并生活在一个后末日的世界里，我的意思是，我认为这其中的生存主义色彩是如此深远，以至于我认为，你知道，预测末日和悲观情绪也是很危险的。我的意思是，碰巧的是，以前这样做过的人都搞错了。所以，如果要把赌注押在庄家输上，你还不如认为，
there are ways in which things get moving again. So I think we have to assume that there are ways in which we can prepare and mitigate. But again, what I think good policy should be doing is understanding first of all what the problems really are. And it's not just that it's going to rain a bit too much, it's not going to rain at all. It's going to snow this weekend. It's what does that actually mean for us all? And how do we have the resilience in starting in our individual countries to have the kind of basic things that anybody should want, which is food supply, energy and resistance to disease environments. And those three big things, I think, are ones we should take the lessons of the last two or three years quite carefully, because there are no tomatoes on the shelves. We've got no energy sufficiency because of Putin. And we've just all been locked down for two years. So if you were to mark current governments all around the world on these three big things that I want to be looking at, it's hard to find someone
你还不如认为有办法推动事情向前发展并改善状况。尽管你的播客中所涵盖的历史充满了可怕的恐怖，你知道的，从大屠杀，到第二次世界大战，到第一次世界大战的战壕，到17世纪，再到查士丁尼瘟疫、黑死病，你知道的，即使在13世纪、14世纪某些情况下人口损失达到50%的情况下，世界，
who's done well. And that's the worry, the investability of leaderships and visions around the world. More historians needed. Seize your chance. They're waiting for you, Tom. Take power. And Dominic, it's the both of you. I do think, I mean, I know you told me off for saying thank you for having me on. I do think that these kinds of podcasts are so vital in opening up the walls of history beyond historians and those who are interested in history generally to much, much wider audiences. And I can't tell you how, I mean, this is what you do all the time,
总有办法让事情重新运转起来。所以我觉得我们必须假设有办法进行准备和缓解。但再次强调，我认为好的政策应该做的是首先弄清楚问题到底是什么。不仅仅是雨会下得有点太多，或者根本不下雨。这个周末要下雪了。这对我们所有人来说究竟意味着什么？我们如何在各个国家内部建立韧性，以拥有任何人都会想要的基本东西，也就是食物供应、能源和对疾病环境的抵抗力。而这三件大事，我认为是我们应该非常仔细地汲取过去两三年教训的事情，因为货架上没有西红柿。由于普京，我们没有能源自给自足。而且我们所有人都刚刚被封锁了两年。因此，如果要对世界各地现任政府在我想关注的这三件大事上的表现进行打分，很难找到一个
so you don't think about it like this. But putting history in the centre of people's drive to work or way home or whatever it is, and trying to connect the relevance of history into contemporary themes, it's not easy to do. But, it's hugely important and the fact that you are you know you've done so it's amazing job in the last two or three years um people like me and other historians but also people who are listening to this will will spark off ideas i mean i'm a very boring academic my job is to inspire the next generation of students but having a platform coming on somewhere like something like this to be able to reach people who i'd never be able to reach otherwise um you know hopefully sets chain reactions for other people who are much cleverer
表现出色的人。这就是令人担忧的地方，全球领导层和愿景的可投资性。我们需要更多的历史学家。抓住你的机会。他们在等你，汤姆。夺取权力。多米尼克，你们两个都是。我的意思是，我知道你因为我说“谢谢你邀请我来”而训斥过我。我的确认为，这类播客在打破历史的高墙、将历史的影响力从历史学家和一般对历史感兴趣的人扩展到更广泛得多的受众方面，是至关重要的。我无法告诉你，我的意思是，这是你们一直在做的事，
than me to start solving problems well bless you peter that's peter we love we love to end the podcast by talking about our own podcast and and the role that we are playing in combating climate but peter you're obviously being insanely over modest because you are absolutely, you know, you're out there. Firstly, with Silk Roads, your international bestseller. And now with The Earth Transformed, an untold history. Although, of course, you have actually told it now because that's what the book's all about. So thank you very, very much. It's a great book.
所以你们不会这样去想。但是，将历史置于人们开车上班或回家途中的中心，并试图将历史的相关性与当代主题联系起来，这并不容易做到。但是，这是极其重要的，而且你们在过去两三年里做得非常出色，像我这样的其他历史学家，以及听这个节目的人都会受到启发，我的意思是，我是一个非常无聊的学者，我的工作是激励下一代学生，但拥有一个平台，能够来到像这样能够接触到我平时绝对接触不到的人的地方，你知道的，这有望为其他比我聪明得多的人引发连锁反应，
A sobering but not entirely depressing book. So thank you very much for coming on, Peter. We will be back next time with another apocalyptic story, won't we? Of course. Do you want to give people a little sense? Do you want to ask Peter his view? So, Peter, we're actually, we tried to think of the one historian who might eclipse you in terms of international reputation and reach.
让他们开始解决问题。好吧，上帝保佑你，彼得。这就是彼得。我们喜欢在播客结束时谈论我们自己的播客，以及我们在抗击气候变化中所发挥的作用。但彼得，你显然是在极其过分地谦虚，因为你绝对是，你知道的，你已经走在前列了。首先是你的国际畅销书《丝绸之路》。现在是《被塑造的世界：一部不为人知的历史》。当然，尽管你现在实际上已经把它讲出来了，因为这就是这本书的全部内容。所以非常非常感谢你。这是一本好书。
And Tom, do you want to tell Peter who it is who we're comparing him with? Is it Dominic Sandberg and Tom Holland? No, no. And very notably, you left him out of your book. It's Graham Hancock, whose perspective on the destruction of Atlantis, you have failed to mention. Is he coming on the podcast live? Maybe the one that was not.
一本清醒但并不完全令人沮丧的书。所以非常感谢你的到来，彼得。我们下次会带着另一个末日故事回来，不是吗？当然。你想给听众一点暗示吗？你想听听彼得的看法吗？那么，彼得，我们实际上，我们试图想出一位在国际声誉和影响力方面可能 eclips（压倒）你的历史学家。
No, he's not. He's not. But we will be back next week um with two specials on atlantis um where does the myth come from what's it all about um was there really an alien civilization destroyed by climate change um and peter will update you on the fruits of that so you might want to tune in we won't we don't want to know your opinion you'll have to wait till next week to find out ours. You can revise your book if you feel that you need to, having listened to it.
汤姆，你想告诉彼得我们在拿他和谁做比较吗？是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克和汤姆·霍兰吗？不，不。而且非常显著的是，你把他的书漏掉了。是格雷姆·汉考克（Graham Hancock），你没有提到他对亚特兰蒂斯毁灭的看法。他会来上播客直播吗？也许那个没有被邀请的。
Anyway, Peter, thanks so much for coming on Earth Transformed and Untold History by Peter Frankman. Thank you all for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Oh, and thanks for having me, guys. Goodbye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History.
不，他不会。他不会。但我们下周会带着两个关于亚特兰蒂斯的特辑回来，这个神话从何而来，这一切是怎么回事，真的有一个被气候变化摧毁的外星文明吗？彼得会向你通报这一研究成果，所以你可能想收听。我们不想知道你的意见，你得等到下周才能知道我们的意见。如果你觉得自己需要的话，听完之后你可以修改你的书。
For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
无论如何，彼得，非常感谢你来到节目中，由彼得·弗兰克潘著的《被塑造的世界：一部不为人知的历史》。谢谢大家的收听。再见。再见。哦，谢谢你们邀请我，伙计们。再见。再见。感谢收听《这就是历史》。